Hello everyone, welcome back to lecture 16 on vectors, iterators, and the standard template library.
If you're wondering about the illustration on the front page here, those are two characters named vector.
That's Vector the Crocodile from Sonic the Hedgehog, and Vector Perkins from Despicable Me, a thinly disguised younger Bill Gates.
So we're going to start today by doing a little review of structures and overloaded output operators.
So you remember for any user defined type, you can overload most of the C++ operators so that the operators will work with your new type.
The syntax for a binary operator looks like this. Whatever the return type, here I've used T, the operator and the symbol, plus, minus, greater than, equal, equal, whatever.
Then a const Tref for the left hand side and a const Tref for the right hand side.
Now the output operator is a binary operator, but it requires a specific value on the left hand side, not a Tref.
And so the overloaded output operator syntax, it returns an OstreamRef.
It takes as its first argument an OstreamRef, the output stream that you're going to print to,
and then it takes only one const Tref, the argument that you're going to print to the output.
Now when the overloaded output operator ends, you return the Ostream argument after you've written to it, after you've changed it.
So we're going to start today, rather than me talking a whole bunch, by doing an exercise.
We're going to write an output operator for the car type.
We want to print the data as manufacturer, a comma, a space, the model, a comma, a space, the miles per gallon, a space, and then the literal MPG.
So let's go ahead and do that. So make sure that you have gone to week four, and in week four it's this last tab on vectors and exercise.
Click the lecture exercise, and the lecture size opens. Click the link for the starter form, and here's the starter form for the overloaded output operator.
Then make sure you've opened up your VS code, and gone to lecture 16, IC 16, and we're going to modify cars.h.
So cars.h has the manufacturer and the model, and we're going to prototype the output operator.
So you notice I've already included Iostream. If we didn't already include that, this wouldn't work.
And because we're in the header, our car structure actually has a mistake in it.
Because we're in a header, we can't use using namespace standard, so we have to make sure that all standard types are fully qualified.
So we have to change it to standard, colon, colon, string, manufacturer.
The same thing with the Iostream operator. So the output operator is standard, colon, colon, Iostream, ref. That's what we're going to return.
It's operator, output, that direction, and it's a standard Iostream, ref. We generally call it out. And then a const car, ref, car for the argument.
So that's the prototype for the output argument. We can add a little documentation to it.
Car, model, mpg, mpg.
I'm not going to put the rest of the documentation inside there. So let's copy that over.
Let's go to cars.cpp. Drop it in there. Put our ID on top here.
Now when you bring a prototype over to the implementation file, we have included using namespace standard over here. That's legal here.
And so if you like, you can go remove the standard if you don't like it. Generally it's just as easy to leave it there.
But if you want, you can go ahead and remove it like that.
Now the output operator is always going to return the stream that it takes as its input.
As its first argument. And we're going to print the manufacturer, model, and mpg. So that is called mfg, model, and mpg are the names of our fields.
So we're going to say out car manufacturer. Notice I've called my variable car lowercase. You could call it c or something like that if you wanted.
Car manufacturer. We want a comma space. Car model. Comma space. Car mpg.
And then we want space and mpg for the output. Now you never put a new line when you're writing an overloaded operator like this. Don't put a new line at the end.
That's kind of a hard habit to get out of.
Okay, let's open a shell on this. Right click it. Open an integrated terminal.
Let's maximize that so we can see it on the whole page. I'll close the earlier one so we're not using up that space.
And let's do make to check the syntax. Okay, no errors. So make test.
And let's see what our mistake is.
Expected. Okay, it looks like the expected output wants braces around it, which we didn't put and it wasn't shown on the slide.
So we'll go ahead and add that fix to it. It looks like everything else is okay.
So we'll put a brace around it there.
And we'll put a brace around it there.
And we'll go check our program again.
So make test.
Okay, so that looks like our overloaded output operator works the way we were expecting it in this case.
Now again, the format I did, there's nothing special about this. I just made it up myself. I decided what I wanted the format to look like.
Okay, so now let's look at our next topic, which is vectors.
So a vector is a standard library list-like container, a sequential container, meaning that you have items in order.
It is a homogeneous collection. That means it only stores items of the same type versus a structure, which is heterogeneous,
meaning that it has fields or data members of different types.
So this sounds like an array. It is kind of like an array, but unlike an array, it's not fixed size.
It will grow and shrink as you need to make it larger or smaller.
Now like all the things in the standard library, it is not automatically included. You need to include it.
The name of the header is, not surprisingly, vector.
Now to create a vector variable, you need to specify what kind of thing you're going to store inside it.
We call this the base type. So here I've said that I want to create a vector variable v1, and I want to store integers inside it.
Usually we'll pronounce this when you're reading the code to yourself as vector of int or vector int.
So v1 automatically is constructed. It's not uninitialized. It's a constructed vector of int, and it is empty.
It doesn't have anything inside of it.
You can, when you create it, specify how many elements you want.
When you create it with elements like that, all of the elements are automatically initialized.
So they are not left uninitialized. They will all be initialized to zero in this case, and v2 is a vector of double.
Now if you wanted to initialize the vector to a specific set of values, that was relatively difficult to do before C++11.
What you had to do was you had to initialize an array. The syntax looks almost exactly the same as Java, if you're familiar with Java.
And then you would pass to the vector the array as the first argument, and then add to the array the number of elements you wanted to read.
Now when we look at addresses in the next lecture, we'll see what this actually is doing.
A is actually the address of the one, and A+3 is the address right beyond the three, and the vector constructor takes that.
Now that's relatively clunky. It requires us to create an extra array.
Wouldn't it be nice if we could do it in line? Just plainly initialize the vector with an initializer list like this,
and of course in C++11, that's exactly what we can do. We can use an initializer list to do this.
So we're going to look at these different versions of initialization. We're going to do our first exercise in VInit.
I believe this is B, so I'm going to go look at it and see if it is B over here.
So let's close A. Let's look at B.
Ok, so put your name on top of it, or your ID.
We're going to create some vectors of short, int, long, and float, each containing five elements of the Fibonacci sequence.
So V1 is going to be a short, and we're going to initialize it from an array.
The first five sequences are 0, 1, 1, 2, and 3.
So I'm going to say int A, bracket bracket, means that's an array, equals 0, 1, 1, 2, 3.
Now I want to copy those elements into a vector, V1.
So I'm going to say vector, the type is short, the base type is short, V1.
And I'm going to pass it A, and A plus, I have five elements, so A plus 5.
Ok, so that will initialize V1.
Now in C++11, this will be V2, which is an int.
We can use a simpler syntax, I can just say vector, int, V2, and I can just supply 5, 8, 13, 21, 34.
So much less work, doesn't require us to create two objects in memory to create an initialized vector.
Now V3, we're going to use a sized vector, meaning I'm going to allocate the size when I create the vector.
So V3 is a long, so vector, long, V3, I have five elements.
Now I want to go through and create, use the algorithm here for the Fibonacci sequence.
So I'm going to create the first two terms, so long, LT1, long term 1, equals 55, and LT2 equals 89.
So there are our first two terms.
Now we'll use a traditional for loop, for size T, I equals 0, len equals V3 size, I less than len, plus plus I.
So your fingers should just type that automatically, you shouldn't really have to think about it.
Okay, so now we want to say V at I equals LT1.
Long term equals LT1.
LT1 equals LT2, and LT2 equals temp plus LT2.
Or we could write it like LT2 plus equals temp.
Okay, so that should move us to 144, 233, and 377 when we do that.
Okay, so remember this algorithm we're going to use in the next two.
Okay, so V4 is a sized vector filled with a range-based loop.
So we're going to do vector, this one's a float, V4, 5.
And we'll say long float term 1 equals 16.
And float term 2 equals 987.
Okay, we don't, and this of course is a float, not a long.
Okay, so this is a different loop here.
Up here we used a traditional loop.
We're going to do 4, auto, ref, E. For each element in V4,
we're going to set E equal to FT1. Let's say auto temp equals FT1.
FT1 equals FT2. And FT2 plus equals temp.
Okay, so pretty much the same algorithm we used here.
Finally we're going to use the same algorithm a third time with an unsized vector.
So let's try that. We'll do vector double V5.
No size on it. While V5 size is less than 5, we'll do something in here.
Okay, so let's create our terms. We had double DT1 equals 6765.0. DT2 equals 10946.0.
So while V5 size is less than 5, we'll do V5 pushback.
DT1, auto temp equals DT1 equals DT2. And DT2 plus equals temp.
So same algorithm, this time we're expanding V5 as we go.
Okay, so this is the four kinds of initialization we looked at.
Let's go ahead and create a terminal on this. Open an integrated terminal.
Let's expand it up there and let's do make test.
And I got V at on line 35, so I have a syntax error.
And this should be V3 at.
V4, V5.
That looks like the only one we made a syntax error on.
Okay, all five of the vectors were initialized correctly there.
Alright, let's look at accessing the vector elements. You already saw me access them there.
So just like string, we can access the individual elements with the @ member function or the square brackets.
If you use the @ member function and you go out of bounds, it will throw an exception.
So it's safe. It's range checked. If you use the square brackets, it's not range checked.
Your program may crash, but not because it throws an exception. There's no range checking on that.
So other operations on vector objects. We have size. You just saw it in the last exercise.
Just like string, the type is vector size type, but we'll of course use size T just because it's shorter and less typing.
You can add elements to the end of the vector, which you just saw us do.
So we can do V1.pushback(3) and that increases the elements by one.
We can remove the last element. Now this doesn't return the last element. It just removes it. This is a void member function.
That pops back and it shrinks the vector by one.
And we have some aggregate operations. Unlike structures, we can compare vectors without a loop.
So if V1 == V2 works perfectly fine.
And you can assign using equals. Again, you don't need a loop for this. These aggregate operations are built in.
Now, when you write a function that takes a vector, you'll first always want to pass by reference or const reference.
So I'm going to compute the average of this vector of double.
Since I'm not going to change any of the elements, it's a const vector double ref V.
So pass by reference or const reference. Never ever pass a vector by value.
Two, use size to get the number of elements and store it in a size T object. Again, not in an int.
Now in this example, I've checked, for instance, if the length of the vector is empty.
It doesn't really have an average. Its average is not zero. The average is the number of elements.
The sum of the elements divided by the number of elements. And of course we can't divide by zero.
Now if you use floating point, you divide 0.0 divided by 0.0, you get the special value, not a number.
So our function average here does the same thing the square root function does when it's passed an invalid input.
Really, if you think about it, if we pass an empty vector here, what we're doing is violating the precondition for the average function.
You can't compute the average of an empty vector.
You can also call the built-in standard not a number function, NAN, and pass an additional message if you want that would display as an error message.
So if we didn't have an error, if we check the preconditions, and again I'm not throwing exceptions in this case,
I'm just doing the same thing most numeric functions do,
I used the range-based for loop whenever you can.
Range-based for loops just make the code much simpler.
And now I can safely return sum divided by len because I know that len is at least one in this case.
Now, imagine that we want to write a print function for vector.
So I'm going to call it just print, I'm not going to return anything.
I'm going to pass in the stream I'm going to print through so we can print a vector to a file or a string stream or whatever.
And of course my argument is going to be a const vector.
That would not be too hard to write, but the problem is it wouldn't work for other vector types.
I have this perfect print function that prints my vector of double just like I want,
and I have to duplicate the code for vectors of shorts or vectors of ints.
So to work for vectors of any type, what you do is you use templates.
So the template definition goes in the header file.
You have to remember to fully qualify all library types with standard.
So you cannot simply put using namespace standard.
And so that template would look like this.
Template type name any type or type name T.
Void print standard ostream ref, fully qualified it, and const standard vector any type ref V.
So we're going to do that in exercise C, vprint.cpp and vprint.h.
So let's put away B and let's go take a look at C.
So vprint.h is where we're going to put our function.
vprint.cpp is only going to have our name inside there.
So I'm going to go ahead and take this comment that I've put inside here.
I'm going to move it over to my header file.
And I'm going to write my generic print function here.
So template type name T or any name you want for T.
Void print standard ostream ref out and const standard vector T, not vector double, vector T ref back.
Okay, now we want the output to look like this.
Notice there's no space before the one.
There is a comma and a space before the other items.
There's no space after the four.
And we have brackets after it.
This algorithm is called the fence post algorithm.
It's one of those algorithms you should memorize until it becomes second nature.
So we're going to print to out the opening bracket.
Then if vec size is greater than zero, we're going to print the stuff inside it.
At the end, we're going to print to out and put the closing bracket.
These are called the delimiters.
Okay, so if vector size is greater than zero, we're going to do out vec at zero or vec sub zero.
If you like, that's perfectly fine.
You know it's there. It's safe.
And then we're going to do for size T i equals.
Make sure you don't do zero here.
If you do zero, you repeat the first element.
One, len equals vec size.
I less than len plus plus i.
And so each one of the remaining elements, we want a comma space.
And then we want vec at i.
Again, we won't put a new line on this print function.
So here is our template function that will work for any kind of vector as long as we can print the elements.
If we have an overloaded operator for a user defined type, that will work perfectly fine.
So this is a generic print function for any vector.
Let's try it out. Let's go ahead and get a terminal there.
And then let's do make. Make sure syntax is correct.
And make test.
So there's v1. v1 is the one we created in the last exercise.
And v2, v3, v4.
And all of those are printing correctly.
Now there's no formatting on the numbers, so we're not seeing that this is a float and this is a double and so forth.
All right. Pretty impressive.
So let's look now at operators and vectors.
Okay. So vector doesn't define an output operator.
We just wrote the print function to print, but it would be nice to do it with an overloaded output operator.
And again, we want it to work with any vector type, so we're going to use a template.
So really the only difference between print is we're changing the name of it to operator arrow arrow.
Now remember a template is not a function.
Instead it generates a function when it's called.
And again, we should place this in a header file.
So we're going to do d.
Leave c open if you've already got it open.
Because we're going to use exactly the same code.
So I've got print open here.
I'm going to go open d.
And in vecout.cpp, I'm going to put my name on it.
That's all I'm going to put in vecout.cpp.
And in vecout.h, what I'm going to do is come over to vprint.h.
I'm going to copy this code I had inside here.
And I'm going to make two changes to it.
I'm going to make two changes to it.
First I'm going to change the name.
Three changes to it.
So I'm going to change it to operator.
I'm going to change the return type to standard ostream ref.
And I'm going to return out at the end of this.
Now again, this only works if we know how to print vector objects.
And if we look at cars.h here,
notice that we already have the output operator.
We wrote that in our first exercise today.
So let's open up a shell on D.
And let's do make on that.
And then do make test.
And okay, so almost the same code.
Oh yeah, it's perfect.
Yeah, 100% of those pass.
100% of them pass.
So C and D were very, very similar using templates to process a vector of a built-in type
and then a vector of a user-defined type.
We didn't have to change the code almost at all.
The first one was print.
And the second one, what we did is turned it into an overloaded operator.
With that, we had to make three changes.
Now, there are several common algorithms that you should memorize.
You should know about counting for a selection.
Count how many vowels are in this string.
Count how many positive numbers are in this array.
Count how many cars get more than 35 miles per gallon.
Accumulation is adding things up.
So and averaging, of course, and standard deviation, all of those,
those are called cumulative algorithms.
You should know about how to find the extreme values,
how to find the largest and smallest, how to process adjacent elements.
So the algorithm we just did was a form of adjacent elements.
Look at the one in front of it, look at the one behind it, that sort of thing,
and how to add separators, which we just did with the fence post algorithm.
Now, different loops are best for different kinds of algorithms.
If you need to visit every element, there's no reason to use a counter-controlled loop.
Use a range-for loop. It's much faster, it's easier.
If you need to keep track of the position, however, then use a traditional for loop.
Don't use a range loop and add an additional counter for it.
The traditional for loop is ideal for that.
If you need to move or sort or shuffle items, you can't do that with a range loop.
Use a traditional for loop.
And if you need to grow or shrink the elements in an array, use an iterator or a while loop.
Now, alternatively, you can more and more just skip using loops altogether.
I can hear those of you who hate loops thinking, "Yay!"
How do you do that? You use the standard library algorithms.
This is part of the standard template library, which was included in the standardization of C++ in C++98.
So, let's look at counting elements.
To count elements which match a condition, first you create a counter for each type you want to count.
So, don't use the regular loop counter.
Create a separate counter that represents the data that you're collecting as you visit each of these items.
You may have more than one counter.
I may want to count the number of cats and dogs I have in an array of pet objects.
Then write a loop that processes every element.
And then, if the element matches the condition, count it and update the counter variable that you have for that.
So, we're going to do our first exercise like that, which is divisible by n.
So, we're going to pass a vector n.
n is the number we're going to do, and we're going to get the numbers that are divisible by n.
So, write a loop that processes every element.
What does that sound like?
The range for loop.
Okay, let's look at that.
That's in D.
No, that's in E.
So, let's put our name on it, S. Gilbert.
So, we will write, we're going to count, so we're going to get an int back.
Divisible by, and we want a vector of, it doesn't tell what type it is, but I'm assuming it's a vector of int.
Oh, actually in the instructions it probably does.
Then the vector int v, which are evenly divisible by n.
Okay, now remember when we pass arguments, the library types are never passed by value.
So, this is a const vector int reference v.
And then int n.
So, we want the numbers that are evenly divisible by n.
So, we're going to go for int e n n.
Now, I frequently will do auto e, just so I don't have to remember what type it is.
So, for n, also then if I decide, oh I want it to work with a vector of double, I can change it.
I don't need to change my code.
But I'll put int here for right now.
For int e in n, so that visits every element.
If e remainder 2, no if e remainder n equals 0.
If e divided by n has no remainder, then we're going to count it.
And let me first create my counter.
So, int divisible.
And so, we'd say divisible plus plus.
Of course, we could use any name for this.
So, that's the basic counting algorithm.
Let's open that in a terminal.
Let's do make.
No, it didn't work.
For e in n, that of course is wrong.
So, I need to say for each element v in v, my vector.
Even if e remainder n, I think that's the only error I have there.
Make, good.
And make test.
Good.
So, in this vector there are 3 that are divisible by 10.
In this vector there are 5 that are divisible by 2.
In this vector there are 6 that are divisible by 2.
In this vector there are none that are divisible by 5.
In this vector there's one that's divisible by 9.
And when you run it, you'll get a different randomized vector in your case.
Alright, let's throw that terminal away.
And let's go talk about how we would do this with the standard library.
So, the standard library already includes this algorithm.
As I mentioned, this is part of the standard template library, or the STL.
The STL has containers, the vector is part of the STL, the deck, the list, the map, the set, and so forth.
And it contains iterators.
So, it contains algorithms, containers, and iterators.
Iterators allow you to access any container type.
But you have to know about iterators to use the algorithms.
So, let me explain what an iterator is.
Different containers store data in different ways.
So, a vector has elements right next to each other.
They're contiguous in memory.
A list stores elements like this.
So, both vector and list are sequential containers.
But with the list, you'll notice the elements are not next to each other.
Thus, they are not indexed.
They are any random place in memory with pointers connecting each one.
So, again, this is sequential.
We start at the beginning, and we go through this maze until we get to the end.
This is sequential.
So, we start at the beginning, we go through this maze at the end.
So, iterators are objects which ignore the physical order
and allow us to select elements from any kind of container.
They're kind of like the claw in an arcade game like this.
Now, we can use iterators with sequential containers instead of indexes.
And we can use iterators with lists instead of pointers.
And so, that means we can write a function, an algorithm,
that works and counts no matter what kind of container I pass it to.
So, how do you get the elements?
Well, you move the claw to the first element, beginC,
calling beginC, where C is the container object that you want to position your claw over.
And so, you'd write that code as auto iterator equals begin list.
Now, we could actually not use auto here,
but it's actually relatively complex, the declaration for that.
You'll learn about it in 250 if you take 250.
Now, we're positioned over this first little space creature.
We want to move it to the second space creature.
How do we do that?
We use the increment operator, use prefix on this.
So, we move to the next element, and now we're positioned on the next one.
How do you know when to stop?
Well, you stop when you reach endC.
Now, endC is not the last element in the collection.
It's one past the last collection.
So, you can say while iterator not equal to endC.
Now, generally, we don't use that with numeric arrays.
We'd use less than, right, less than size.
But with iterators, you always use not equals.
Now, that's for moving the claw through the collection.
How do we pick up an item?
Well, we pick up an item by dereferencing it.
Dereferencing it simply uses the same symbol we've used for multiplication,
but as a unary operator in front of an iterator.
We'll also use this operator, the dereferencing operator, in front of pointers
when we get to that.
So, this picks up the item and puts it in the variable value here.
So, we're going to write the same function we just wrote, divisible by,
but instead of using a loop, we'll use iterators.
Instead of using a for each loop, we'll use iterators to do that.
Okay, so let's close counting in E and let's go to F
and put our name on top of it.
Okay, so this time we're writing it using an iterator loop.
I've already written the header here.
So, what we want to do is we want to create a counter.
So, int divisible equals zero and return divisible.
So, that's the skeleton for the structure of the stub.
Now, we want to loop through using an iterator.
So, for auto iter equals begin v,
iter not equal to end v, plus plus iter.
So, again, we're not doing an index, we're moving this little claw.
Now, the element is star iter, right?
That's how we pick up the item.
So, if star iter divide by n equals zero,
or star iter remainder n equals zero,
then divisible plus plus.
So, this is an iterator loop.
By the way, the for each loop just writes an iterator loop behind the scenes.
This is writing an iterator loop manually showing the code.
So, let's test that. Let's open a terminal.
Let's do make test.
And this one still works just as well.
So, there's one seven, one eight, no tens, two fours, and so forth in these arrays.
And again, these are randomly generated, so you'll have different values there.
So, here is our iterator based version of divisible by.
Now, most of you are probably thinking, "Oh, great, another way to do exactly the same thing."
That's not actually very useful.
Actually, I'm going to talk about that in a second.
Let me talk about constant iterators first.
Iterators permit you to change the items they refer to.
A constant iterator, i.e., vector const iterator, does not.
Begin will return a const iterator when the container is const, and a regular iterator when it is not.
Now, beginning in C++14, you can actually use cbegin and cend to explicitly state that your iterator won't change the items.
So, you can use that when you don't want the container elements changed,
although, generally, I have to say, most of the time, just using begin and end is perfectly fine.
Okay, now let me talk about algorithms.
The STL has a collection, or several collections, of pre-built algorithms.
So, there's a collection in the header algorithm, there's another collection in the header iterator,
there's a collection of numeric algorithms in the header numeric.
And so, here is how we would use the count algorithm from the library.
We'd create a vector v, and we'd count from begin v to end v, or in this case, we could use cbegin v and cend v.
It wouldn't make any difference for 3.
And that would tell us the number of 3's that are inside there, and we would not have to write a loop at all.
Now, how do we write, though, and how do we call the count function when what we want to count for is a condition?
Well, first, you have to write a function that represents that condition.
This is called a predicate function.
A predicate function is a function that returns true or false.
So, isEven takes the integer n and returns n remainder 2 equals 0.
Now, and then, once you've written the function, you would pass the name of the function instead of 3 or 4
to the function called countIf.
You don't pass it to count, this is a separate function.
So, countIf beginC endC is even, and that would return you the number of even values.
Now, that's not quite what we want to do, though.
We don't want to check to see if it's even.
We want to pass in a value for this 2 right here.
We want to pass in a value for that 2.
So, that requires us to use an anonymous function rather than a predicate function like this.
This anonymous function is called a lambda.
A lambda starts with a set of square brackets like this.
The argument list, just like we'd have in isEven, and the comparison here.
So, this countIf does the same thing as this countIf, but doesn't require you to create a separate isEven function.
We've just written the function right inside the argument list.
This function does not have a name like isEven.
Now, suppose we want to write our divisible by function using countIf.
Well, I could countIf e remainder 2 equals 0, but how do I countIf e remainder n equals 0?
Well, I do that by capturing here in the square brackets any additional variables I want to use in the body of this function.
So, I'm going to show you how to do it.
We're not going to do this a lot in this class, but I just want to introduce you to it.
So, you can get a picture of the fact that you can write C++ code without really using a lot of loops.
So, we're going to write for our next exercise divisible by using an algorithm instead.
And then you'll have three different versions of this in E, F, and G of the same function using it three different ways.
So, this is S Gilbert.
So, here I'm not going to create a counter. I'm not going to do anything.
I'm just going to return countIf beginV.
Or you can actually write this.
There is a member as well, so I can write v begin if you want.
I actually like beginV and endV instead.
And then on the next line I'm going to put this beginning of the lambda expression.
And inside that I'm going to put what I want to capture.
So, I'm going to capture the variable n.
And this function is going to take one argument.
So, I'll call it the element in E for each element.
Inside the body of this I'm going to say return E remainder n equals zero.
So, notice this function is just an argument inside that function.
Now we need to end the function here.
So, you might find this less readable.
But it actually makes your code much simpler.
Notice we don't have any loops inside here at all.
Okay, let's try that out with g.
Let's do make.
Make test.
Notice it still works exactly the same.
But the code is somewhat simpler.
And you don't have to format that.
You can format it just like you would a regular function.
And then put that over there.
So, you can make your functions easy to read in other words.
Easy to read.
So, this is called a lambda or an anonymous function that can be passed around as an argument.
It can also be stored in a variable.
So, we can use vectors to return a collection of items.
Suppose we have a vector with duplicates.
And I want to write a function that removes all of the duplicates or only keeps the unique names.
So, I'll write a function named unique.
The returns of a new vector with only the unique values.
So, here's the unique algorithm.
We're going to create an empty vector result.
We're going to visit each element in the input vector.
Then we're going to check to see if that element is in the result.
If it's not, we're going to add it.
And then we're going to return the result.
Now, this algorithm is relatively slow because we aren't assuming the vector is sorted.
If the vectors are sorted, it would actually be relatively fast to do it if the vector was sorted.
Okay, so let's write unique using loops.
So, let me open that up.
Close counting.
Close these bash shells here.
Okay, so this one now is going to return a vector.
So, vector int unique const vector int ref v.
So, here's my result.
Vector int result.
And, of course, I'm going to return the result.
Okay, so I have a stub, something that would compile, and something I could test.
Now, we want to visit each element in that.
So, I'm going to say for auto e1 in v.
Now, I want to see if it is inside result.
So, found equals false.
I'll say add.
Bool add.
Bool add equals true.
For auto e2 in result.
If e1 equals e2, then it has already been seen.
It's a duplicate.
And, add equals false.
And, actually, once we know the answer, once we know it's a duplicate, let's just break out of that loop.
Make it a little bit easier.
Then, after the inner loop, now remember what we're doing.
I just created an empty vector result.
Visited each element in the input vector.
Now, I'm looking to see if it's not in the result, then I'm going to add it.
Okay, not in the result, then I'm going to add it.
So, how do I add it?
I say, if add, result pushback e1.
So, this is creating a new vector, going through and seeing if it's in the result.
Okay, let's try a shell on that one.
And, let's do make test.
Okay.
So, here's my original vector, here's the unique ones inside that.
Here's my original vector, here's the unique ones inside that.
Here's my original vector, here's my original vector, original vector, original vector, and the unique ones inside each case.
And, you can see, like this one has two fives there, skip the five, it has two fours, one four there.
Alright, so one last thing we're going to look at today
is how do I insert and delete items, or how do I insert and erase items.
So, if you insert something into a vector, the vector has to expand.
So, if I want to put six where this three was, I have to move the items to the right and add the six inside it.
And, the vector gets larger by one.
Now, to do this, to call these functions insert or erase, you have to use iterators.
Indexes don't work.
However, iterators have an interesting property.
If you add a number to an iterator, you essentially get the iterator that would represent the index.
So, when I say v_begin, I'm representing, it's pointing to v at zero.
v_end is pointing to the element that would be at v_size, which of course is beyond the end of the vector.
If I take v_begin, or begin v, and I add one to it, however, I'm no longer pointing at the element zero, I'm pointing at the element one.
If I take v_end and I subtract one to it, I'm pointing at the last item.
Now, there's one other complication you need to think about when you're inserting and deleting.
That complication is the size of the vector changes,
and any iterators that were already pointing to things are invalidated.
So, as you can imagine, if I had an iterator that was pointing to this three, and I inserted the six,
now it would be pointing to the six instead of pointing to the three, so it would be invalidated.
So, often students will try this.
This is trying to erase all elements.
So, we're going to see if cppShell opens here.
It did. It opened in another browser I have, so I'm going to bring it over here.
So, here I have, here's my print function that we wrote earlier today.
And so here I have an array with one, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
And I'm going through the array with a counter-controlled loop,
and at each element I'm trying to erase the item in it.
Now, the intention of this programmer was to erase every item.
That's not what happens.
And you'll see if you run this, that we have seven items.
We try and erase the first item, and it does in fact go away.
We have that.
And then we try and erase the item at position one, because our index has gone forward here.
And so, notice we skip over the two, because our index is now pointing to this three.
And so we delete the three, then we delete that, and so we end with these three elements left in the array.
Not really what we intended to do.
Oops.
So you have to remember, when you erase something, the items kind of under your feet are going to change.
So we're writing one last exercise here.
This is a modified version of Unique.
It's going to remove all the elements from the existing vector v.
And I'm going to give you a little bit more practice, or show you a little bit more about using iterators instead of loops.
So let's use Unique.
Put our canvas ID on it.
Okay, so this is going to return the number of duplicates removed.
So int.
Again, is not required to be sorted.
We're going to keep the last, not the first element that we find.
Of course, that will determine how the output is sorted.
It's called Unique.
It's a vector.
Oh, it's not a constant vector. It's a vector.
Int.
And it's changed.
Okay.
So first we want the number of dupes.
So int dupes equals zero.
And we're going to return the dupes.
Now we don't create a separate vector.
What we're simply going to do is we're going to use an iterator to look at each item.
And the easiest way to do this for erasing is to use a while loop.
So we'll say auto iter equals begin vec.
And we'll say while iter is not equal to end vec.
Okay.
So now I have to see if -- so I'm looking at the first item.
Does that item appear anywhere else?
So the pseudocode.
Yes, erase it.
No.
Look at the next -- look at the next element.
Okay.
So that's my pseudocode.
So I need to say for auto -- I'm going to call this iter two.
Auto iter two equals iter plus one.
Iter two not equal to end vec.
Iter two plus plus.
If star iter equals star iter two.
That means I found it.
So I'm going to erase it.
I'm actually just going to set found and break.
So bool.
And let's not even have a break in it.
Let's just put that condition here.
Not found.
Okay.
So this was -- does the current item appear elsewhere?
Yes.
If found, then erase the item.
Now v vec erase that iterator.
Else iter plus plus.
Okay.
Or plus plus iter.
We kind of don't want to use -- we don't want to use the negative one on that.
So notice that this iterator is looking, starting at the next one after it.
It's looking to see if it's found inside of that.
If it finds it in the else one, it deletes the current one.
It deletes the current one.
Otherwise it leaves it there and it goes to the next one.
It goes to the next one.
And actually, this invalidates the iterator, so we should write it like this.
And that gets back what that new iterator is pointing at.
Okay. Let's see if we got it here.
And let's open up a shell on this.
Let's bring that up.
Let's kill the first one.
Let's do make.
Make test.
Okay. It didn't work.
Oh. You know what I forgot to do is -- so I'm getting the correct outputs.
V after works.
So I got plus plus plus.
I got 50% of the points.
But every time I find it, when I found it, I want to say dupes plus plus to count the number of duplicates there.
Okay. There's 100%.
So before we had this, I remove five of them, and after I have that.
So notice seven appears last, even though -- if I kept the first one, it would be 57261.
57261.
Because I'm keeping the last one, it's 52167.
All right. So that's it for lecture 16.
When you come back, we will look at memory and pointers.
I'll see you then.